les revenus du japon sans long et égouts
encore iso kumi doria à partir de
maintenant il est recherché dans tous
les axes routiers se retrouvent leur qui
dessert près du landeron héron qui se
trouve déjà sur plainte a remis un
mandat d'arrêt sur midori à ce que tu as
pu
mettons nous au travail pour le salut de
l'humanité pour le salut de l'humanité
ado je suis vraiment désolé maintenant
toi aussi tu es un criminel le héros
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut 6 me
coltine les courses
le mât rise l'organisation idéologique
ça ne nous empêchera pas de contrer les
terroristes uva prend le serbe on a plus
que vous vous êtes les héros de l'avenir
j'ai toujours voulu devenir un super
héros et sauver les gens en danger avec
le sourire les héros j'ai trouvé l'amour
en charge de la nettoyer
je vais vous tuer toi et tous tes amis
site à nous protéger les super héros ils
sont en danger le monde entier l'est
[Musique]
rien n'est perdu rachat jamais
d'affaires baissera pas les bras on
abandonnerait pas on n'est pas du genre
à jeter l'épongé facilement il est temps
de lâcher la faire maintenant héros nous
on a un critère pour s'encourager
laissant les autres
delà des limites
plus
[Musique]
my hero academia le film world of heroes
michonne la partie est terminée